nous sommes en direct avec hicham mourad
éditorialiste à al ahram hebdo est
professeur de sciences politiques à
l'université du caire bonjour hicham one
merci beaucoup d'être en direct ce matin
avec nous sur rt france est-ce que vous
pouvez nous rappeler le contexte de la
rupture diplomatique entre entre le
caire et ankara il ya huit ans oui c'est
d'abord vivre biologique qui oppose les
deux pays
comme vous l'avez bien expliqué dans le
port reportage
la turquie soutient majid el islam
politique sunnite alors que l'egypte
s'oppose complètement à l'islamisme dont
l'ensemble de la région dans le monde
arabe et au moins une est en général et
en plus comme vous savez également bien
expliqué dans le reportage la turquie
dry certain nombre d'opposants en
particulier ceux qui appartiennent à la
mouvance islamiste en particulier des
entendu les frères musulmans et voilà
donc ça a reposé sont des opposants donc
sans pause les deux pays
sur ce plan idéologique bien sûr il ya
d'autres questions d'ordre régional qui
oppose les deux pays
mais je dirais que ça c'est le franc ou
la base essentielle de l'opposition
entre les deux pays et qui a causé la
rupture depuis 2013 alors qu'est-ce qui
a fait que il y a quelques mois
maintenant la turquie et et le caire ont
décidé de se rapprocher
écoutez la
[Musique]
il ya une évolution régionales il ya
plusieurs développements au niveau
régional qui ont fait que les deux pays
ou en particulier la turquie a pris des
démarches ou des initiatives dans ce
sens d'abord il ya la question de la
libye la guerre civile en libye
il y a maintenant une dynamique de paix
qui a commencé à être enclenchée depuis
l'été dernier en particulier depuis la
conclusion d'un accord de cessez-le-feu
va le 23 octobre dernier et la volonté
des deux pays de ne pas se montrer dans
un conflit militaire sur le sol libyen
donc cette proposition ne peut pas durer
indéfiniment
puisque si bas pour servir leurs propres
intérêts il dort 126 p quand même sur ce
qui se passe on lit sur le la suite de
cette dynamique de paix donc sur un
règlement politique
il ya également cette réconciliation qui
a lieu depuis janvier dernier dans les
pays du golfe entre le qatar d'un côté
et les autres
l'arabie saoudite et les émirats de
l'autre côté mais aussi le bahreïn
egypte se ranger du côté de ceux de sète
ce camp qui s'opposaient à au qatar or
il ya maintenant une réconciliation
entre ces pays et le qatar et le prépare
comme vous le savez était également un
allié de la turquie la turquie est un
allié du qatar donc toi normalement
maintenant se ranger du côté de cette
réconciliation et profiter de cette
détente dans les rapports entre les pays
du golfe y compris les gîtes aussi et le
qatar donc tout si cette évolution
et puis il faut pas oublier non plus que
il ya une troisième question qui ont osé
l'egypte à la turquie c'est la question
de la
de l'exploitation des ressources
gazières en méditerranée orientale et
bien sûr la turquie exclut complètement
de la coopération régionale qui se
déroule actuellement entre plusieurs
pays producteurs et consommateurs en
méditerranée orientale
il s'agit essentiellement bien soûl de
l'egypte mais également d'israël de la
grèce de chypre et de l'union européenne
aussi et pour le moment la turquie est
complètement exclue alors que lg a
cherché bien sûr avec assise l'idée je
dirais être d'être intégré dans cette
manne gazière et donc c'est l'une des
raisons également qui pousse la turquie
à se réconcilier avec l'egypte et
chercher une entente sur cette question
d'abord à travers une démarcation de la
frontière maritime entre les deux pays
est ce que l'arrivée aussi au pouvoir de
joe weiden aux états unis a changé la
donne oui peut-être un petit peu ça
pousse un petit peu dans cette direction
parce que ça m'arrange pas ni la turquie
et l'egypte
les rapports ne semble pas au très beau
fixe en tout cas entre la nouvelle
administration et la turquie et la
nouvelle administration éligibles donc
salée les me pousse un petit peu à se
les concilier pour faire passer un petit
peu à 7
je n'ai pas cette froideur de la part de
la nouvelle administration américaine
alors il ya une délégation qui se rend
au caire une délégation turque on n'est
pas encore un rapprochement à haut
niveau
est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à une
rencontre dans les semaines à venir
entre le maréchal el sissi et le
président turc recep tayyip erdogan
je le pense pas tout de suite à mon avis
pour assister au sommet je ne pense pas
qu médias en tout cas l'avenir
prévisible
je pense que ça va jouer encore au
niveau
[Musique]
subalternes et pas forcément souhaitable
ça peut aller jusqu'au niveau
ministériel
y'a rien qui l'empêchent mais il faut
d'abord qu'il s'entend et qui
s'entendent il faut faire des
concessions réciproques et ça c'est pas
forcément facile à faire
ça peut être possible bien sûr on les
dit mais ça sera plus difficile par
exemple sur la question de
l'exploitation du gaz naturel ont mené
très orientale
pourquoi parce qu' il n'est pas question
ici de deux parties bilatérale se sera
pas ça se jouera pas au niveau bilatéral
parce qu'il ya également la grèce il y à
chypre il ya israël et surtout pour la
grèce et chypre
il y à de gros problèmes concernant la
division de l'île la division de chypre
entre les deux la partie grecque et le
parti turc et surtout qui vit à déjà
avait déjà conclu des accords de
démarcation de leur frontière maritime
avec la turquie avec chypre et pour
pouvoir le faire avec la turquie il faut
que déjà il faut il qu'ils s'entendent à
l'egypte s'entendent déjà avec les deux
parties des autres partis grecs et
chypriotes
ce qui ne sera pas une chose facile
il ya des divergences importantes
concernant la démarcation de la
frontière maritime entre bien sûr chypre
et la turquie et la grèce et la turquie
et l'egypte nous pouvons faire fi de ces
accords juridiques qui ont été conclus
là était conclu en 2003 avec chypre et
le deuxième avec la grèce était conclue
en août dernier outre 2020 donc ça sera
pas chose facile
donc il faut en tout cas elle est que
les deux parties et fasse des
concessions et et il y à pas mal de
questions qui sont encore en suspens
notamment la question de l'érable
de l'existence des frères musulmans en
tout cas la présence des frères
musulmans de l'emprise opposants sur le
sol cube et ça c'est pas le cas encore
réglé et la question vous l'a soulevée
en turquie et qui abrite vous l'avez dit
beaucoup d'opposants égyptiens elle et
les sympathisants en tout cas du du
président mort si les le ton a changé
ankara a dit d'ailleurs aux médias de
mettre un peu d'eau dans leur vin en
parlant de de duke r ça fait partie
aussi de cette stratégie de
rapprochement
oui bien entendu mais beaucoup tourné
pour l'egypte c'est pas suffisant à la
demande est bien entendu il ya trois
chaînes de télé qui diffuse à partir
d'istanbul qui appartiennent aux frères
musulmans qui sont affiliés aux frères
musulmans leur demander d'arrêter les
émissions politiques critiquent le
régime égyptien
et ça c'était bien sûr un premier pas
l'egypte demande plus demandent deux
choses d'avoir que c'est c'est que ces
stations enfin que ces chaînes soient
fermés et également l'extradition des
dirigeants des frères musulmans qui sont
demandées devant le tribunaux en
l'egypte est donc cet édifice en suspens
et on verra quelle sera la position de
la turquie sur cette question
particulier vous parliez la grèce 1 qui
voit plutôt d'un mauvais oeil ce
rapprochement qu'en est il de la france
on sait emmanuel macron est un grand ami
entre guillemets du maréchal sicié à qui
il vend beaucoup d'armes
comment est-ce que c'est perçu par les
européens et en particulier par la
france puisqu'on sait aussi que manuel
macron à quelques problèmes avec le
président turc notamment sur la
rhétorique
oui bien aujourd'hui ce nouveau problème
la france était un allié de l'egypte
et là une question primordiale
concernant le soutien de deux régimes
nature à l'islam politique dans la
région y compris en libye et à une
question bien sûr de la question des
réfugiés silien et tutto enfin et bien
sûr également
il ya des questions et changent très
acrimonieux de des discours entre
erdogan et le président pense et
emmanuel macron et ça fait partie
également des problèmes qui se posent et
l'egypte
aussi doit également tenir compte
je dirais un doivent en tenir compte des
positions d r d or mission de la france
mais aussi comme je viens de dire
position de la grèce et de chypre 300
pi2 sont membres de l'union européenne
donc et qui sont des alliés de l'egypte
et l'egypte doit avancer je dirais
prudemment pour ne pas également
froisser ses alliés de longue date
merci beaucoup et chanoine pour toutes
ces explications merci d'avoir répondu
en direct à nos questions sur rt france